thank you JC the Halloween party is not
over after Monday Alicia Angel Alicia
Cerna of love chocolate dessert shop is
back to show us a new trick for your
leftover treats I love this idea so tell
them what we're making because I'm so
excited
um so now that it's cold outside we're
going to be making hot cocoa bombs and I
figured you always have a ton of
leftover chocolate after your kids go
trick-or-treating if you're passing out
chocolates so we're gonna make some
cocoa bombs um you can pretty much use
any kind of chocolate you like I like to
use Stovers which you can pick up at
your local craft store it's perfect a
crafty cake shop so all you have to do
is you want to go ahead and help me with
it yeah I do let's do it all you have to
do is go ahead and pour it in here oh
and this is such a good family you know
fun activity or activity you can do with
your friends at a party your kids family
all of that so all you want to do is
just code it you can go ahead and do
this okay oh gosh don't compare mine to
hers please and what I love too about
this is you can pick whatever chocolate
candy you want and that changes the
flavor exactly the bomb right so we're
going to be doing Reese's for an example
but any chocolate that's in the candy
that you're getting you can add inside
and also on top okay so after you hear
what's your favorite my favorite is
Cookie made cream a little Hershey's
white chocolate Okay so after you coat
it you would typically put it in the
refrigerator or the freezer just for a
few minutes to save time
we already have them out so you want to
double coat them and go ahead and take
it out it's really easy because since
they're silicone it pops right out I
don't know how fun typically you'd have
a hot plate and then you would just put
it on the hot plate and that acts as a
glue so then you'll stick them together
and it would turn into a Coco bomb and
we have about 45 seconds left so I want
to make sure we get this product we went
ahead and just added Reese's Pieces on
top and then you see all the beautiful
details she teaches you how to do that
on her IG her yeah talk and then here's
the hot cocoa you can top it with
whipped cream sprinkles and the fun part
if you've never done a hot cocoa bomb is
you drop this ball into the hot cocoa
right the hot milk the hot milk excuse
me creates the hot cocoa marshmallows
come fluffing up this is so cute tell
everybody where they can follow you for
all your I can follow me on I love
chocolate dessert shop on Instagram Tick
Tock and YouTube oh my oh this is good
thank you so much thank you for having
me happy Halloween we'll be right back